this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks everyone for for tuning in to
episode three the Cornell Turf Show
we're in season four of this thing uh
thanks to the live audience I know it's
getting a little warmer up here kind of
in central New York people probably out
and about today but uh as Frank I'm sure
we'll we'll talk about today we might
see a little bit of a pause here in the
growing season coming up uh so as always
you know tune in on Thursdays and
Fridays if if you can't get out and do
some work uh Frank yeah I've got a I've
got a rant uh prep for today we're going
to talk about some bunkers here and and
my grievances with bunkers but as always
I'll turn it over to you and uh and have
you kick us off with some some thoughts
on how the growing season's progressing
in in the next couple uh days or so
what a life this guy's got right I think
that's Tori I think it's either Torrey
Pines or somewhere in La uh what a
lovely picture uh lives of dogs right we
started out with this so long ago Carl
and we're and we're still doing it the
the cute pictures of dogs right you just
you just can't beat him but I thought
this was really an even better one I I I
think this was from some place in
England uh I don't I sort of just
misplaced a tweet and couldn't see it
but you know this is always you know
this used to be a pretty standard
practice on golf courses around the
world that this this particular problem
when you look in the history books Carl
of Saint Andrews and the way they manage
the lynx courses you know they didn't
have synthetic fertilizers in this late
1700s early 1800s they were slinging
animal manure animal manures pretty much
all they had and as you built those
Sands up with Organic Matter worms were
literally threatening the game uh there
were so many until the ammoniacal uh
nitrogens came on uh sulfates came on uh
and began to be applied uh to irritate
and kill these things and then we
embarked upon a heavy metal uh you know
application regime which lasted the
better part of a hundred years uh
because you know you put them on once
they work a really long time so we're
continuing as everyone knows you know
this problem is not going away it's sort
of I wouldn't say hiding in the weeds I
think for some people it's an absolutely
major problem that has caused a lot of
adaptations I think car later in the
season we're gonna probably get Kyle or
Paige uh or Ben who who had some very
interesting findings just talk about
worse because you know it's one of those
things that you don't pay attention to
and we don't have you know saponin base
products to provide some at least
alleviation of the issue this isn't
going to get any better just one more
note a little announcement
um we next Thursday I will not be on the
show uh we will let you know what it
what the adaptations will be moving
forward uh for this because I'm doing a
walk and talk uh at yanandas's Golf Club
in New Hartford New York uh as part of
the gcsas NYS walk and talk series we're
going to be talking covers Carl they
took down a lot of trees and of course
we always have a little BMP conversation
and it will be the first day for I
believe a Texan on his way North uh to
be the golf course superintendent uh and
it will be his first day of work and
Chris will uh come back uh for that walk
and talk as well so it should be a very
delightful place now Carl before I pass
it over to you Jan Das is pretty cool
place right is that Donald Ross uh it's
similar Walter Travis it's got some
spectacular topography and you mentioned
to your removal you can actually see
that topography now the clubhouse looks
looks over all of it it's it's pretty
stunning as a as a visual and all right
but here we go here we go I'm ready I
started I thought I'd you know this is
every golfer's worst nightmare in fact
they were talking at it talking about it
quite a bit on the telecasts uh the PGA
telecast this weekend where you know it
hit it would hit and roll out right it
wasn't always a fried lie but but it
costs a lot to do this Carl
yeah and and that's what what sort of
turned me on to this is last week I saw
this tweet from the USGA you know they
made a video really kind of detailing
why sometimes we see inconsistency in in
bunkers right sometimes it'll plug in
there right it hits and stays in the in
the Friday Glide now that's that's
really tough as a golfer sometimes it
hits and rolls out sometimes there's no
real impact it's firm enough it kind of
rolls around and they had a really nice
video sort of detailing all the
variables that go into how that sand
plays and how even just at one golf
course if they're doing all the same
things to every bunker you're going to
get variability so they mentioned stuff
like irrigation uh heads how they're
situated around a green if there's some
overspray into certain bunkers based on
how those heads are oriented those
bunkers are going to play you know
firmware they're gonna have higher
moisture content and if you're getting
no no none of that overlap irrigations
could be softer they made a really nice
nod to the direction those bunkers are
facing so if they're in the South
Southeast Direction they're getting
hammered by the sun they're going to dry
out faster even if you're trying to
water them and firm them up those are
going to play softer and they're going
to play softer as the day progresses
versus the bunkers that are in the north
northwest direction right they're not
getting as much sun they're they're
drying out slower they're playing firmer
and I think this is really interesting
to understand because a lot of times
when golfers complain about bunkers it's
something like and you'll hear PGA Tour
Pros talk about it this this bunker had
no sand but that bunker had a lot of
sand and sometimes they're not saying
what they mean and we know this dealing
with maybe some athletic from soccer
coaches or something Frank where really
what they mean is this bunker played
firmer or this bunker played softer and
they don't like that they like
consistency and and what I would say is
you know first of all bunkers you
shouldn't you shouldn't be there in the
first place so there probably should be
some variability in there the second
thing I'd say is the best way to
identify bunker players is to give them
variability and to test them hey you
have to figure out how this ball is
coming out we do that with rough right
Ruff never has the same lie when you Mr
Green that's right yeah if they get a
spin is it going to fly on you right you
have to read the lie and I would say the
same thing for bunkers so this is not a
bad thing that there's that there's
variability in bunkers uh but but when
we look at the cost to maintain bunkers
Frank this is where it starts to get
pretty crazy and this is some some
initial data from USGA Deacon tool where
they collected uh data from the golf
courses that were using it and
calculated you know hey between the
labor between the between the materials
between the equipment costs what does it
cost per acre to maintain the various
playing surfaces on a golf course
obviously the greens are number one
they're right they're receiving the most
in 10 intense maintenance this this
graphic has it about seventy thousand
dollars per acre that probably varies
wildly but the interesting about this
table is you look at the bunker Number
forty thousand dollars per acre to
maintain bunkers right that's you know
60 to 70 percent of what it costs to
maintain a putting surface that is an
enormous amount of money
and when you look at some other research
the USGA has done where they've asked
golfers about their playing preferences
on certain playing surfaces they
classified bunkers as a what they call a
dissatisfier so that's a surface that is
prone to creating a negative impact when
it's not managed appropriately
but it doesn't provide that extra value
the better you maintain it you could
have a perfectly maintained bunker and
you have to spend so much more to
achieve that versus maybe some minimum
standard that the golfer likes and a
great way to sort of uh explain this is
a bunker you know you go into a bad
bunker I've got a picture of a bunker
that's waterlogged here the golfer
obviously uh does not like that right
and that creates a negative image in
their head that they hold for the entire
round
but if you spend a whole lot of money
and then maintain that bunker the best
it could possibly be the golfer's not
coming out of that bunker Frank and
saying man that was the best bunker I
have ever played out of in my life that
was so man they don't they didn't ever
come away from a golf course singing
praises at bunkers right so maybe
there's this minimum acceptable level we
don't know what that is but that will
maximize your inputs uh and how you have
to maintain these areas and not not go
that extra level uh but where I'm where
I'm really going to place some blame
here Frank is is Architects that use
bunkers as a crutch and I'm not going to
single any any specific ones out I've
got an image here of of a golf hole that
literally has maybe 40 to 50 bunkers on
just one hole and Architects love the
visual aspect of bunkers there's these
flyover bunkers Donald Ross famously put
what he called a top bunker in front of
the women's tees when he used to design
courses to penalize bad shots right and
that's just a waste of time to maintain
that bunker how much value does that
give you what I'd say is there's a
there's a there's a less expensive way
to maintain features similar to bunkers
and that's these ground features I've
got on the screen Lyndon golf courses
with cool little Community Golf Course
short course up in Syracuse uh the
initial course had a lot of these sort
of Walter Travis bunkers we're talking
about yanandas similar same architect
here very cool features right and they
can provide the similar sort of playing
uh strategy and and Aesthetics as a
bunker and they're less less uh cost
intensive right and there's another
photo here guy Cipriano taking a picture
is a couple of these Mounds right and
it's interesting the ball is rolling are
you going to get the good bounce or the
bad bounce and it's so much uh less to
maintain these areas it's not nothing
right it's there's still some
maintenance going on here but I would
just say I would challenge Architects to
really think about every bunker you put
on a golf course think about that forty
thousand dollars per acre number and is
it worth is it worth me putting this
bunker here right Augusta National has I
think I think it's around 40 bunkers
there's around two per I think at
Augusta National that's not many right
and there's there's courses with over a
hundred right so obviously good golf can
be played with with few bunkers per hole
and I would challenge some Architects to
to maybe be a little bit more uh
thoughtful about how they're they're
laying those out okay we'll get to the
shade you just threw on architects in a
minute Carl but um I I think the
dissatisfier thing is is really the
driver here right it's it's really the
driver because you can't win right
there's no winning there's only there's
only there's only finishing you have to
produce them and from there you're right
you're exactly right no one ever comes
off the golf course and say oh that was
those are beautiful bunkers you won't
hear it very often unless they spend a
lot of time in them and they're really
good golfers which one happens more than
you know than the other so I think that
dissatisfier point is really good for
the mindset uh you should have when
you're discussing them right and you
know we've talked about where to put
them based on the the Deacon data the
GPS data that we are looking at right
that's a that's a growing use of of that
particular data now the other thing
that's fascinating about this uh rant
for me is you and I are always barking
about Fairway age reduce Fairways reduce
maintenance on Fairways Fairways
Fairways and now I'm looking at this and
saying well you know compared to bunkers
I think we what we ought to do is figure
out what this crutch is about because if
you're telling me that these what we've
always said about these large amount of
land that we're managing we talk about
it from an environmental impact
perspective right not necessarily from a
maintenance perspective it does add
maintenance because you got to spray and
do all the other things when you're
treating for pests but that's a pretty
profound statement that you know I you
know I'd like to look pound for pound
you know when I look at this picture on
the left here with these you know snaked
waste bunkers that travel the length of
the Fairway that you know somebody I
know well does really good and they say
well you don't have to rake them every
day and then you get them and you got to
rank them every day because the people
are out there using them and they don't
think they think about it just like it's
a green side bunker and and not waste
bunker so
um talk a little bit about the crutch
because Tom dog said to me once Frank if
we didn't have bunkers people wouldn't
be able to tell it was a golf course
from the road
that's what he said to me in a time he
visited here once so talk a little bit
about what you think they're using it
for as a crutch is it a penalization
that you think is easy to do and doesn't
really could be achieved other ways I
think the first first and foremost is is
I think that penalization aspect right
hey if you're if you're taking on this
this left pin and and I want to penalize
you for taking on that risk hey here's a
bunker and we're gonna put it really
deep sad and make it hard to get out of
um so so it definitely starts with
penalizing sort of sort of bad shots but
there's also an aspect of depth
perception and I've heard Gail talk a
lot about this and and how deep a bunker
is and how it's set in next to a green
or near a fairway it distorts how you
view the whole Aleister Mckenzie was
famous for uh he started in in military
Warfare and and how to build trenches
that the enemy couldn't see and his
course is famously you'd look back from
green to tea and you couldn't see the
the bunkers but they would affect you
visually so there is certainly an aspect
of that that color definition how you
build into a hillside or into a fairway
and how the golfer sees that hole but I
would also say that you can achieve
those same things with these these Turf
features and if you use different
varieties maybe different turf grass
varieties you plant some fescues on
there that have a different color you
can build them up and make them visible
from the tea you can achieve those same
sort of things and you can still get a
penal nature yeah and you can still
drive over most of these things with uh
with a mower some of the ones little
ones on the right might be a little
tricky but those you could also do
eyebrows right Josh fontaine's got them
at Saratoga golf a lot of places have
these drops uh right where they if they
get a little hairy on the top
um and those are really penal you'd
rather be in a shitty bunk excuse me
you'd rather be in a bad bunker than in
in that snotty stuff right so I love
this we I but let's keep moving because
we could spend the whole time yakking
about this and let's talk about getting
going for the season here's a really
nice uh another depiction I think this
is a golf course uh somewhere in Europe
uh on maybe in the British Isles where
you can see they've got a top a compost
applicator here uh that they're putting
on their Fairways and this was about a
week apart or two weeks apart when they
took these pictures uh very similar you
can see by the Sea
um and and the dramatic nature that
warming that system up with just
anything dark right colors uh covers
we'll talk about that next week pigments
can be a big part of this so let's talk
about what's going on during the growing
season we'll do a little walk through
the weather soils are hovering in the
upper 30s to 40s region wide if you
recall last week they were creeping into
the 50s so we've really hit this pause
button
um it may be coming to a close soon but
not uh necessarily in the next week
um we were about 2-40 degrees above
normal if you looked above New York City
and a little bit cooler to the South uh
up cooler and closer to normal to the
South but as we look forward normal
temps are expected right and this is
that perception thing normals are in the
30 to 40s for the next uh week for this
time of year normally I mean you might
creep into the 50s and 60s for a day or
two certainly downstate you will but you
look you know you can see we're not
going to accumulate more than 10 to 15
Growing Degree Days you know north of uh
north of New York City and just south of
New York City maybe about 20 Growing
Degree Days for the whole week so not a
big uh not a big progression necessarily
from a temperature perspective let's
look at the all-important moisture
perspective right and that's last week
it was slightly wet to the west of the
region but just slightly a little bit
above normal when you look at you know
precipitation minus evapotranspiration
which you know you're not getting a lot
of water loss it gets wet it stays wet
typically this time of year and then it
was getting drier to the east uh and
South and we talked a little bit about
this dry area in Central Jersey that's
getting a little bit of a relief uh just
today
um it's very interesting looking back at
last month's precipline if you look at
you know about a 30-day period of
rainfall there's this swap of wet uh
precip almost 200 percent of normal in
some places uh that if you drew a line
across the the Northeast region from
Buffalo to Boston right in about a two
three hundred mile range it's it's
pretty moist uh dry to the South and dry
to the north of this line so just in the
last month you're starting to see uh the
moisture situation uh begin to shape up
on our native soils now it looks like
moving forward we're going to get a
couple of fronts moving through so I'd
expect some more rainfall this coming
week for the region-wide that appears to
be showers coming in at different times
depending on where you are in the region
but everybody's going to get a little
bit I think art even said maybe up up to
up to an inch so it's going to be a a
good slug of rain uh and and not all the
places needed as that previous uh image
indicated so now we're going to get to
the heat part of this and and the Crux
of the conversation today that I think
is good because this has been coming up
now this seed heads depression topic has
been coming up pretty regularly Carl
since we started so early in February
right so so you know as you can see on
our on our website we have both Embark
for those of you who still use
mafluidide and proxy degree day models
based on some research that uh we
conducted in our program back about many
years ago 2005 2006 when proxy came to
the market and was really going to
revolutionize things we did it at skinny
Atlas Country Club and we did it at Oak
Hill and we developed these models over
a couple of years that said here are the
ideal conditions so those uh
mathematical models based on January 1st
grow in Degree Days right we accumulated
for the whole year in our model you can
see we are passing Prime throughout the
Metro New York area and as you move up
and we're still not in the uh we're
still a little early as you move north
uh you know the Connecticut Coast
Southeastern New England Coastal New
England is currently in an ideal pattern
for seed head suppression and so it's a
good time Carl talk about the degree day
model stuff right so the gdd tracker
which starts accumulating February 15th
and missed the warmest January we've had
is indicating you've got some time uh in
some of these areas before it's too late
in fact it's saying that the ideal range
is right where the Cornell the New York
model says we're passed and this is an
indication of the how you use these
Growing Degree Days to design your
approach right you know you have to
decide which model you're going to use
have you tried these what works for you
because I've also heard people say yeah
I hit it on the 8th and 12th green but
man I missed it on the 15th and 16th you
get micro environments you got different
populations of Poa these models for this
stuff is only going to be so good so
that's what really made the fall
application stuff that we'll talk about
in a minute really important because you
can do it consistently but I thought I
would revisit why are we doing this what
is this about what happens to the plants
when you restrict reproductive growth
and you allow it to continue some form
of vegetative growth how does it affect
annual Bluegrass performance and I've
talked about this before actually I dug
so many slides out of the turf show I
think we did a few years ago this is
Rich Cooper's work from the 80s look
who's the last author on this the Tony
Cosby this is back when Koski was a
technician and Cooper were technicians
in Ohio in the early 80s late 70s early
80s when Embark came to the market and
one of the things that they found out of
the gate was that when you suppressed
seed heads you had uh more structural
carbohydrates stored energy reserves in
The Roots this indicated that the plant
had Reserve energy that it somehow
conserved energy from uh you know flower
production see that production and moved
it into stored energy into the root
system uh using Embark so this was
pretty revolutionary it also had a
significant effect on Rudy elongation
right looking at it over a number of
months the high Embark rates that were
suppressing seed heads were also leading
to significantly more rooting it's like
this is win-win right this is where the
whole idea not just of doing it for
performance but for doing it for uh
plant Health was really important so the
there you go this is also a very
interesting point that they made at the
very bottom it actually mentions the
rebound effect this is something we all
still have to consider and this is
really the basis of Bill kreiser's work
years ago when he began to start looking
at how Primo degraded in the plant and
if you didn't apply the Primo at the
right time you got this Surge and growth
well this was observed even back then
you look at the root you know
substantial decrease in leaf stem and
root tissue following growth inhibition
the carbohydrate levels went down in the
tissue when the growth surge occurred so
this is the sort of talk about is this
really helping the plants
so let's go back to how we do it and
then we'll get back to whether it's
really helping the plants and this is
Sean askew's work from 2015 where he's
looking at trying to time it in the
spring only uh applying it in what he's
calling winter with a snow mold
application and then a follow-up spring
application right and what you see both
with proxy and Primo is that if you
apply a winter application of proxy for
example you're even with you know with a
single spring application you you know
you're still getting exceptionally good
uh seed head suppression out of the gate
so I don't know about the timing of the
spring but you're locking in a lot of
improvements if you look at the
difference from Spring only which is 25
and winter in Spring that's uh 82 you
see a 60 percent just get that
application down in the fall and you
don't have to worry as much in my
opinion in about time in the spring
thing the other thing is that was Sean's
work in 15. Zach Riker led a collection
of regional scientists a number of years
ago published this paper in 2019 about
looking at this across these regions and
they had a Connecticut region in there
that's saying the fall application date
is best November night the initial
spring application date this year if
you're starting on January 1st look like
about uh base 32 look like about 350. if
you're using Growing Degree Days on a
first or 15 start so here's that thing
Carl where it depends on where you start
and what it means you know with how
you're going to look at these models and
they did it across these regions the
thing that's interesting is right
they've interest introduced proxy and of
course Primo now okay so what does this
let's say okay
we've been doing it it makes sense it
looks like we've dialed in how to do it
a very small piece of work was conducted
by John anguajato look at the dates on
this call 2005 2006. I remember Bruce
Clark when he used to come on our
conference call on Thursday mornings
actually would talk to us about this
they had identified this uh early on
that potentially was involved so this is
a study where they looked at the effect
of seed head suppression using Embark
proxy and Primo applied alone and
together the Primo wasn't applied alone
the um the Primo was only applied with
the things with the two seed head
suppressors right because Primo doesn't
suppress CNS interestingly when they
used Embark alone they got an increase
in anthracnose between 14 and 30 percent
they put Primo in there it decreased
anthracnose between five and eleven
percent proxy alone
and proxy looks like the key here proxy
alone decreased anthracnose 13 to 35
percent
compared to not using seed head
suppression proxy and Primo pretty much
the same so Primo seems to Safe in some
of the Embark stuff it seems to Safe in
not it doesn't have that same impact on
proxy but definitely proxy is an
advantage if you're struggling with
anthracnose these uh tools would be then
important uh things interesting little
uh contrast there uh with the um you
know with the uh uh the Embark that has
the health benefits that Cooper showed
but not those benefits manifested so
listen I'm going to wrap up here but I
wanted I thought we'd uh chat a little
bit about pulp putting quality right we
see seed heads on putting greens we've
talked about how these po annual greens
out west get a bad rap but it also
changed the whole location on these
screens too and it's an indication of
the traffic we've talked about how
crappy golfers are even good golfers are
from 10 feet here's some Mark Brody data
that a PGA tour pro makes a 10 foot or
only 4 out of 10 times and then remember
you you share this Lou stagners had this
we get worse over the course of the day
they miss a a 10-footer an eight foot or
even more uh as as the day goes on
the the GS3 which we're going to get
Elliott on this thing or we're going to
get zapped or we're gonna get one of
those USGA guys on or on here to talk
about this but this is one of those
things Carl that seed heads also have
this effect potentially on putting
quality now you've looked at Spike
damage how would you rate seed head
damage I'll stop sharing how would you
rate seed head damage uh or seed head
you know presence with spiking on a
green
yeah so so we've used the Bible test
when we do our traffic studies uh we use
What's called the Bobble test which is
uh in a way subjective basically you
roll a ball and you count how many times
it Chatters which is it doesn't leave
the ground but it sort of bobbles as
it's moving up and down vertically how
many times it's snakes which is sort of
this left to right horizontal movement
and then a bobble is is when it comes
off the ground like it hits something
pops up and that's really easy so we
we've rated traffic through through that
Bobble test and you consider all those
things and it goes from one to nine uh
and so when we see a lot of spikes
especially Spike shoes that have an
external Spike on them we've tested
metal shoes you'll get some some bobbles
where it hits a spike Mark and the spike
Mark is so physically present that it
chops the ball up and the ball hops up
in the air and it does something when
we've tested these spikeless designs
generally what we've seen is that we
don't get so much of that that leaving
the ground but we get what we call
chatter so it's kind of it's It's
oscillating as it's moving across the
ground it's not really snaking so we
really see those when you get Spike
marks from external spikes you see
snaking you see bottles spikeless design
is more of this chatter and and
sometimes those things don't really
separate themselves out when you're
using this Bobble scale and we've talked
it with the guys at FootJoy now about
hey maybe we should differentiate
between that chattering where the ball's
not really leaving its line versus a
snake where it it sort of veers off and
it really affects the the line of the
putt so when I think the seed heads and
and most of the time what we're seeing
with seed heads is that chattering it's
it's probably a lot like a lot of the
spikeless shoes we would test where it's
it's it's noticeable for a golfer right
the golfers seeing that golf ball
oscillate up and down but is it really
changing the line of the Putt and that's
what I think we're more interested in
when you see a real big deviation and
how the ball deflection right we call it
deflection two that's really influential
on how that putt should have gone and
maybe how it got knocked off course John
asked he's working Virginia Tech has
looked at this with with uh little spots
of Poe a little dollops of Poa and it's
in a newer bent grass green and how that
deflection something like eight
millimeters yeah can affect how you you
make a miss or putt yeah so you know
when I'm thinking about seed head
suppression it's probably more of that
chatter domination that that you would
see from a golfer perspective which if
I'm really grasping at straws here I'm
thinking that's probably not going to
affect the outcome of a putt right
that's what we care about from 10 feet
of PGA Tour makes it 40 of the time yeah
is it 38 with with the seed heads maybe
I don't know but probably not as much as
but in super slow-mo Carl in super
slow-mo it looks really bad but the
point is your point is well taken is it
coming off line and Sean asks you's work
where they use that strike plate yeah
right that's how they were determining
but that is a relatively uniform surface
as a bent grass with a dollop of Poa in
it when you look at the picture I show
earlier you got a uniform standing pole
you got seed heads everywhere you got
you know tight Poe everywhere it would
be you'd think more of a of a chatter
we're at 10 30 we're over time do we
have a question we want to take or what
yeah so so Ben polymer has a good
question about those grass feature
amounts we were talking about and and I
mentioned briefly in there you know hey
these are lower maintenance than bunkers
but they're probably not no maintenance
right well they're not he's asking hey
you know do those dry out more right
they're elevated they're probably not
holding water as much do you have to
hand water growth regulator wedding
agents we've talked about this with with
our guy Josh managing those out at
Saratoga Golf and Polo do you want to
comment I told them to burn them I told
them to burn them I think that I don't
know if you can get away with it but
that would be the option just to get
some of that organic material added air
um I or or or strip it off those things
are best when literally they're growing
on subsoil many years ago Jim scarowski
uh coined the term I liked he calls it
he called it Mantra agronomic principles
right instead of promoting fertile
fertile soils and soil Health get rid of
that stuff use it somewhere else and use
these areas to restore really bad soils
because that's what grasses and these
metal systems are are good at and I
think they do dry out Ben I think they
can be more maintenance and I think that
we have to be careful right I mean we've
already seen this happen in in Native
areas on golf courses where that that
level of herbicide use a a company that
will go nameless sends out a regular
email which talks about the five or six
different chemicals you got to use on
these native areas so you are correct I
don't I think Carl's right we don't want
to suggest no maintenance I think our
vision Carl it's run the mower over it
or the ventrac over it not turn it into
this you know multiple chemical
applications
nicely right there's there's got to be
some variability let's take the
variability we're okay with that let's
okay all right let's get out of here
we're late yeah well a little bit over
time but nonetheless still was was a
fast 30 minutes Frank thanks for joining
me uh tomorrow we'll be on with kale
Bigelow from Purdue we're going to talk
about some early season fertilizer
growth rate stuff uh so tune in for that
in our Lawn and Landscape uh episode but
until then thank you all for joining
live and and uh we'll see you tomorrow
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu